[Music]  Tessa Thompson is back in Cree too and  she opened up to et about returning to  set with co-star Michael B Jordan to  make that another one and to have so  much of the same cast and crew come and  join us and to welcome some newcomers  and you know rocky has been a franchise  that has been around for over 40 plus  years when people are still engaged and  we're really excited to bring that film  and that energy to a new generation and  to build something that is our own so  we're just so happy that the fans  continue to come with us on this journey  me first time you see Michael B Jordan  amazing physique the reaction it's hard  to remember because people just like to  google him is that it takes a tremendous  amount of work so I'm just so proud of  him that he puts that work in and you  know it's a big part of playing a  boxer's to see is to really nail that  physicality and he doesn't more than to  the boxers